Let's talk about placement
of the Cast Icon.
Last time you went to a friend's
place and turned on their TV,
you probably grabbed their
remote, pressed the power
button, and on it came, because
the power button is always
in a consistent location.
That's why we insist
on having the Cast
Icon in a consistent location,
at the top of your app.
The actually existence of the
Cast Icon is like a reminder
that there are Cast devices on
the local network they can use.
So that makes it
simple to work out
whether there's a Cast
device they can see
and they can control
from your app.
You shouldn't make
your users have
to dive through a bunch
of menus to try and find
the Cast button, and
that's another reason
to stick the icon at
the top of your app.
Because what you really
want is for users
to feel right at home the
first time they use your app.
And that'll keep them
coming back for more,
and that's the name of the game.